[Music]
good morning John it's Friday June 29th
good morning John it no I'm not gonna do
that two days in a row
thanks for yesterday's video I'm really
glad that we finally got to share some
of what we saw in the dominican republic
it's kind of strange that I felt so
grateful to be able to experience that I
guess I would have assumed that I was
going to feel sad or mostly really
guilty I was afraid I was going to feel
extremely guilty I was also afraid that
I was going to feel extremely scared but
somehow I didn't feel either of those
things maybe I should have but I didn't
I guess I probably felt less scared
because we had an armed guard with us
the whole time
in its first year this program had like
three robberies and they had to take
some kind of steps to stop that so now
there's always a driver and the driver
has a gun when we first got there mostly
I just felt really awkward and out of
place obviously it was a very different
world from the one that I'm used to but
what you didn't share with everybody
yesterday and what I think is really
important to share is that after we
stood up in front of all those women who
were having their graduation ceremony
that day we started to ask them
questions and we asked them questions
like what kind of business are you
starting up but then they started asking
us questions and they asked us questions
like where are your sisters and are you
married and then they all argued about
which one of us was cuter and you won I
don't know what I expected
poverty-stricken people to be like but
for some reason I was surprised when it
turned out that they were people and I'm
ashamed to admit that but I will admit
that they were just people and they have
a community and they hang out with each
other and they do a lot of the same
things we do just not the things that
cost money but for some reason my
previous experience with people in
poverty which is limited mostly to
television commercials gave me this
impression that they were somehow too
sad and too downtrodden for me to be
able to relate to them in any sort of
way that's complete
they're totally diss people this
happened to be people in really horrible
situations and they were nice and funny
and if it wasn't you know scary and kind
pressing I wouldn't mind hanging out
with those kind of people also I would
have to speak much better Spanish and
while these people definitely need lots
of help in lots of different ways
microfinance is a really powerful way
for these people to improve the quality
of their own lives and you're right it's
like giving money except you get it back
afterward I mean I don't want to be a
pure capitalist here but that's pretty
good deal so I'm going to keep it out
work right now and I'm gonna find
somebody and I'm gonna sponsor them and
I'm gonna put a link to them on
Brotherhood to calm and we're gonna get
that person their loan this is Karina
and Dino sanabria and she's a saleswoman
and she's building a business in which
she sells clothing right now she needs
$575 and I'm going to loan her $200
there now she only needs 375 dollars
look how happy she looks
I know what you're thinking you're
thinking that was it it was that easy
yes it's that easy and then you get your
money back in six months and Karina gets
to run her business basically it's like
investing except that the interest rate
isn't very good you could invest your
money in Exxon but you wouldn't feel as
good about that as I do about this keep
it on org yeah I don't think anybody
gets this excited about donating money
ever but it's not donating money
it's loaning money but it feels like
donating money it feels good but you get
your money back microfinance yes it's
that easy
John I'll see you on Monday